[Musique]
mon voyage se poursuit dans le loiret
l'un des départements de la région où se
concentrent beaucoup d'athlètes qui se
prépare pour les jeux olympiques dont
l'escrimeur sans drogba zaz et orléans a
d'ores et déjà neuf sites sportifs
labellisé terre de jeux 2024 pour les jo
de paris notamment la salle d'armes
christian d'oriola où je me rende ce pas
le cercle d'escrimé orléanais connaît
déjà une renommée internationale grâce à
manon brunet et cécilia berder qui ont
déjà participé aux jeux olympiques de
rio et qui seront également présentes
pour tokyo mais la nouveauté cette année
est bien si la présence de cendres au
base à des géorgiens licencié dans le
club
il est actuellement à l'intérieur de
cette salle et se prépare avec ses deux
maîtres d'armes
[Musique]
voilà vous voyez où l'on tend surtout à
l'ambiance est studieuse ici au cercle
d'escrimé orléanais et d'entraînement et
quotidien on a une partie de l'équipe
qui est ici et j'ai d'ailleurs un des
entraîneurs ici responsables de haut
niveau arnaud finanière merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui alors en ce moment
ils sont en train de s'échauffer on va
dire un peu plus dur que les chauffeurs
l'échauffement est terminée et là ils
sont en train de faire là près de partie
de préparation physique ici ce cercle
d'escrimé or les années c'est quand même
le plus haut point de l'escrim en france
sur le sabre sur ça je pense que oui en
lien c'est un peu le graal je pense en
terme d'organisation on organise aussi
une du monde à côté de ça on a des
athlètes olympiques donc manon brunet
cécilia berder qui s'entraîne
aujourd'hui à l'insep sans drogba that
they qui lui ira pour la géorgie qui
s'entraîne avec le maître boere mais
qu'est ce qu'ils viennent chercher pour
vous ici vous voyez la salle déjà ça
c'est la première chose
mais c'est pas la chose essentielle pour
moi c'est des hommes qui font les
structures et pas l inverse donc du coup
je pense qu'ils viennent chercher de la
compétence humaine aussi on fait du
travail sur du long terme
moyen terme est très court terme la
cendre on est en plein dans le très
court terme
est ce que je vous propose c'est que
vous discutiez un petit peu avec lui
allez on y va
bonjour sandro elle l' os android jo
[Musique]
merci de m'accueillir ici depuis combien
de temps tu es ici à orléans depuis plus
d'un an
j'avais déjà combattu pour orléans en
équipe et nous avons gagné une médaille
d'or à roubaix est une compétition
nationale
c'était un grand plaisir pour moi de les
rejoindre parce que c'est un grand club
historique
mais qu'est ce que tu aimes
particulièrement ici je me sens comme à
la maison
les gens l'entraîneur c'est comme ma
famille c'est le meilleur endroit pour
me préparer pour les jeux je suis
heureux d'être ici et ya beaucoup de
chance parce que le plus grand maître
d'armes au monde et ici à orléans
christian bauer c'est pour cela
d'ailleurs que tu es venu c'est le
meilleur depuis un ou deux ans il est le
meilleur depuis minimum et il a gagné
beaucoup de médailles olympiques de
championnat j'ai beaucoup de chance que
je suis heureux d'être son élève
aujourd'hui jason d'excellentes
découvrir comment vous y préparer
c'est le maire
[Musique]
pour
non
où
j'avais mis je te présente le meilleur
entraîneur que bonjour m voyeur merci de
m'accueillir alors là évidemment depuis
tout à l'heure en fait on découvre ces
grands préparatifs pour les jo de tokyo
soroma évoqué un petit peu son parcours
quelles sont ses qualités c'est
quelqu'un qui a une motivation
extraordinaire déjà quitté la géorgie
pour venir s'installer ici ça prouve
déjà qu'il est à 100 % dans le projet il
a des qualités physiques hors normes il
est encore perfectible dans plein de
choses mais c'est un garçon attachant et
qui s'engagent voilà donc ça c'est
parfait qu'est ce qu'il fait en ce
moment quel programme en fait vous
l'avais prévu on fait beaucoup
travailler tactiquement bien sûr fait
beaucoup d' analyse aussi les des futurs
adversaires
le but en fait c'est d'avoir toutes les
chances de notre côté info mission après
dans tous les domaines parce que les
jeux olympiques c'est 99 % dans la tête
que ça se passe
merci beaucoup
[Musique]